And the answer is all the above. As we just spoke
about, it's nice when you have a separate app server, database, cache,
all of the, all of those separate pieces because different web
applications have different needs and over time you may add features that
strain the system in different ways. So having all of these
separate systems means they can be
scaled and operated independently. Increasing fault
tolerance is a great reason. You know you don't want to
have, the fact that your caches are bad, to ruin you know,
all the parts of your website, you know maybe parts of your
application don't need the database, so don't need the cache, there's no
reason why one system should you know, ruin another. Or if you
lose them you know, one cache machine, you shouldn't lose the ability to
handle app server requests as well. So two different processes aren't competing
for resources, whenever we talk about this one, but you know we've
got an apps server and a database on the same machine. They
use your computer in very different ways and having two machines running one
an app server and one a database. And ma-, many
cases under high load will actually doubly out perform a single
machine. Because you've got the machine can make use of its
own caching. You know, the processor cache and the OS cache
and all that sort of stuff. That will be constantly being
trampled by, you know, your app server tramping, your database caching
and vice versa. So separating processes that behave wildly differently from
each other onto separate physical machines makes a lot of sense.
And also so these systems can be updated independently. Say you want to
switch from PostgreSQL to MySQL or you want to switch from Memcache to Redis
or something like that. Well, there is no reason why you need to
take down the rest of your site to do that. You can update these
pieces one at a time you know as, as you need to. So,
these are all reasons why you want to separate your services and it's good
even if you have all these services on the same machine initially that
there's some kind of walls between them.
So that, you know, have them communicate
over tcp or communicate over some other sub system such that when you
switch to having separate machines, you don't have to rewrite your whole web
application, you know you don't have
to re architect everything, you just kind of
moving different programs around. So that's kind of
one of the big keys to scaling.